time now for one more thing
he complained about it so we are going
to give him what he wants piers morgan
happy birthday
and yes we have all the good stuff
really bad for you but it's good we're
going to give this to you too here i'll
take some of this
this is for your flight home thank you
it's been a great three days thank you
thank you you've all been very very very
good are you ready
i'm not on tomorrow all right but he's
on your show yes he's on my show on
friday what's in the box
look at the box my favorite line we're
going to get into this but first we're
going to go to dana while we eat
anyway happy happy birthday it wasn't
pretty funny when you said we forgot
your birthday would you like to see he
did not forget his birthday all right
season two of everything will be okay
the podcast it drops on monday april 4th
uh foxnewspodcast.com so i have a lot of
great guests i'm very proud to say
country music star walker hayes who the
judge played i interviewed him and the
co-founders of minute mentoring and mike
rowe will talk about dirty jobs for
girls which will be great also the
paperback version of the book is now
officially on sale and i'm going to sign
books this saturday at the little point
book shop in point pleasant new jersey
at 2 p.m eastern so swing by uh i'll be
there but percy will be there so that's
your draw
all right uh tonight on jesse waters
prime time we have a bunch of good
guests but we also booked the pansexual
nymph that greg mentioned yes live
from the magic kingdom to talk about
what's really going on in disney world
so definitely tune in at seven o'clock
eastern now greg is your turn i forgot
tonight i have the judge you're on
tonight yep it's gonna be fun we're
gonna talk about a lot of stuff but
let's do this i'm having this greg's
short friend news all right as you know
being medium height i can't fit into a
lot of tight places that's why i let
dana hang around with me because she's
tiny and i can put her in places that i
can't get to just like this pair this
guy is having a hard time getting the
ball but his buddy
gets the ball
i'll get it there you go next time you
know show the dog struggling at the
beginning they're always editing for
time and they end up ruining it
all right i have some cheesecake i can't
i'm gonna
stop you look great thank you all right
judge what do you think okay if you know
me then you know i love a dog that has
confidence check out this cute pup who
really knows how to pose for a selfie he
even has perfect timing take a look my
poogles are definitely not camera shy
yeah that's a cute one okay first thing
in the morning they all jump on my bed
to wake me up this is what i see that's
ted i haven't used an alarm clock in
years thanks to them here are pictures
of them morning photos on top of the bed
they don't care they just jump
like time to get up that's ted and red
here's morgan well i've got this
i don't understand why people i'm sorry
for looking ridiculous but i rather like
it
why would anyone base jump you know when
they throw themselves off cliffs with
little parachutes
and this is the answer as to why you
should never do it because this guy base
jumps up and then gets trapped
on a rock for an hour
with basically the the parachute bit
shredded
and all the others had gone and then he
just thought they'd forgotten about him
and was going to spend the rest of his
natural life suspended from his rock
uh so it just confirmed my i have one
phobia in life
the one thing i hate is guys no how did
it no he got he actually remembered that
one of them hadn't come
feeling i had when i hosted the greg
gutfeld show
pure terror
special reports up next with bret baer
thanks jesse you know piers it's been
great seeing you on air all this week
but i have to say that was a little
premature birthday whining
yes i agree happy birthday
happy birthday
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else